في موسم
2012-2013 وصل ريال مدريد الى نصف نهائي
دوري الابطال واجهوا مانشستر يونايتد
وكانت المره الاولى لرونالدو يواجه فيها
ناديه القديم
واضح ان رونالدو قد عاد ولعب واحرز
الاهداف حين كان لاعبا في صفوف مانشستر
وكان حتميا عاجلا ام اجلا سيواجه
اليونايتد ريال مدريد وسيتحتم على رونالدو
ان يواجه اليكسون الذي يمكن له احتراما
كبيرا وقد لعب في ملعب اولد ترافورد بقميص
ريال مدريد في ربيع عام 2013 خلال بطوله
دوري ابطال اوروبا في دوري 16 تغلب ريال
مدريد على مانشستر بهدف في ملعب برنابيو
وقد سجل رونالدو الهدف طبعا ثم في مباراه
الاياب في كانت مباراه مثيره للجدال كان
لاعبون مانشستر غير راضيين عن الحكم ومن
يسجل هدف الفوز لريال مدريد انه كريستيانو
رونالدو لم يحتفل امام مشجعي مانشستر
لانني اظن انه جزء منه ويحمل احتراما
كبيرا لهم لكنه حريص على فوز فريقه الحالي
يستدير اوزيل ثم يمرر يرسل هيجواين كره
عرضيه ويتقدم ريال مدريد يعود كريستيانو
رونالدو لاحتفال بالهدف رغم النتائج
الرائعه لريال مدريد كانت المباراه عرضا
حقيقيا لنبلى اخلاق رونالدو وحساسيته تجاه
ناديه القديم عام 2014 تابع ريال مدريد
فوزه بهدفين مقابل لا شيء في كاس السوبر
الاوروبيه ضد اشبيليه احرز رونالدو
الهدفين لمدريد وحصل على جائزه رجل
المباراه التي سلمها اليه السير اليكس
فيرجس في مباريات كهذه من الصعب دوما
اختيار رجل المباراه ثم تلاعبون جيدون كثر
في الملعب لكن كريستيانو جعل الاختيار
سهلا علي الليله
اشكر السير اليكس فيريكسون على منح هذه
الكاس وهي تعني للكثير لانه كان المدرب
الذي علمني اشياء عده حين كنت في صفوف
مانشستر يونايتد في سن الثامنه عشره لذا
اقدر ذلك لك واشكرك على منح هذه الكاس
خلال سنوات القليله التاليه ابحر رونالدو
نجم مدريد وبقي يحطم الارقام القياسيه مع
النادي محققا علامات فارقه ومستمتعا بكل
مباراه لعبها وبعدما اصبح مجددا مسجله
اكبر عدد اهداف في دوري الابطال
2013-14 امس بسهوله افضل لاعب في العالم
لا تتحقق الانجازات الاستثنائيه لرونالدو
بسهوله يجب ان يكون في لياقه بدنيه فائقه
لذلك وبالطبع كان رونالدو دائما اهلا لها
وفي اواخر العشرينات من عمره كان في افضل
حاله اقوى واسرع مما كان عليه يوما وكان
يحطم الارقام القياسيه في الميمنه
والميسره والوسط احرز مئه هدف لريال مدريد
في مباريات الدوري في شكل اسرع مما حققه
فرنش بوشكاش محطما رقمه القياسي الذي ظل
صامدا عقودا من الزمن من حقبه كان فيها
احراز الاهداف اسهل بكثير مما في العصر
الحديث سجل 200 هدف لريال مدريد في 197
مباراه انها ارقام متعاقبه مدهشه ومذهله
بينما تتهاوى الارقام القياسيه امام مجهود
كريستيانو رونالدو البطولي في نادي ضم بعض
اروع اللاعبين الذين رايناهم يوما وربما
باتوا يحظون باعظم لاعب في تاريخ النادي
رقم ستيفانو القياسي ورقم بوشكاش القياسي
وهو ما زال يحرز الاهداف لم يتعرض لاي
اصابه ويلعب اسبوعيا هو وميسي شخصان
مدهشان من خلال هذا التحدي الدائم
للمستحيل فقط ومن خلال الموهبه والاصرار
يمكن الوصول الى الابديه وهذا ما فعله
كريستيانو رونالدو منذ هذا الاسبوع
كريستيانو رونالدو هو الهداف الافضل طوال
تاريخي ريال مدريد الحافل
324 هدفا خلال 380 مباريات وهذا متوقع من
قبله والمعجبون يزدادون كل يوم وهذا
اللاعب يحاول ان يصبح افضل وهو دائما يعد
بان يكرس حياته للعبه وبالا يتركها وان
يناضل دوما في سبيل الفوز الى ريال مدريد
لم اكن اخطط ابدا ولكن عندما ارتديت للمره
الاولى قامص ريال مدريد وصممت ان اكون
افضل هداف بتاريخ النادي الاعرق والاكبر
في العالم واستطعت منافسه صديقي راؤول
والمرحوم الف رينو استفانو لذلك اريد ان
اقول انني في الحقيقه فخور بالفريق
منذ تولي بلغريني الذي طور ريال مدريد حتى
مورينيو وتشيلوته والان
بنستي وبفضلهم ايضا
لانهم ساعدوني في مسيرتي لكن الى جانب
مسيرته مع ريال مدريد كان ايضا اللاعب
النجمه لمنتخب البرتغال المشارك في بطولتي
كاس العالم واوروبا اعطي دور قائد الفريق
خلال افضل مواسمه في مانشستر يونايتد وكان
يعد القدوه لجميع اللاعبين وصولا الى
بطوله اوروبا 2016 ساعد دوره في الفريق
على اجتياز الطريق نحو النهائي ومواجهه
فرنسا لكنها لم تكن مباراه يسيره على
رونالدو بل كانت في الحقيقه من اشدها وطاه
عليه على الاطلاق في سن صغيره جدا حين كان
رونالدو مشاركا مع منتخب البرتغال لبطوله
امم اوروبا لعام 2004 حين خسر النهائيه
على ارضهم عام 2012 بلغوا نصف النهائي
وامست تلك المباراه نقطه سوداء في مسيره
رونالدو الدوليه في نصف النهائي في دوناسك
حين لجاوا الى ركلات الترجيح امام اسبانيا
وقد انبرر رونالدو لتنفيذ الركله الاخيره
لكن لان زملائه ضيعوا رك لاتهم لم تصل
البرتغال الى لاعب الركله الاخيره خسروا
ركلات الترجيح امام اسبانيا حتى قبل ان
ينفذ رونالدو ركلاته
[تصفيق]
بفارق بسيط تنتقل اسبانيا الى المباراه
النهائيه مجددا يبدون اول فريق يدافع عن
هذه الكاس كانت خيبه امل كبرى بقميص
المنتخب الوطني ثم في امم اوروبا 2016
وصلت البرتغال الى النهائي في مواجهه
فرنسا واعتقد الجميع انها ستكون اللحظه
التي سيلمع فيها رونالدو مع منتخب بلاده
على المسرح الكبير ليكسب كاسا للبرتغال
للمره الاولى بوجوده معهم ثم اصيب في
بدايه المباراه
[تصفيق]
تقرا علامات الحزن في وجهه عمل بجد وانتظر
طويلا ليبلغ هذه اللحظه ويلعب النهائي مع
منتخب بلاده وحين يتم ذلك يستمر بضع دقائق
فقط تشعر بان رونالدو مرغوب فيه دوما ان
يكون الرجل الذي يدير العرض وعمليا ينتهي
به المطاف بتدريب الفريق حتى انه يكاد ان
يلبس معطف المدير الفني على خط الملعب
ويقودهم الى النصر على فرنسا في النهائي
وفي شكل مذهل من دون رونالدو في الملعب بل
بتوجيهاته من مقاعد الكادر التدريبي يغدو
المنتخب البرتغالي بطل اوروبا انه الحلم
الذي تحقق بطريقه لم يتصورها احد
لكنها اعظم ليله في تاريخ البرتغال الكروي
لرونالدو من الدموع الى الاهازيج والمزيد
من الدموع لكنها دموع الفرح هذه المره
انها الكاس الكبرى الاولى لهم رغم
الصعوبات كلها